by the way if you've never met Eddie
he's six three just so you know yeah
assalamualaikum greetings of peace all
right before we get into this exclusive
interview with Patrick Ben David and
myself
we'll show a few clips from it Jake how
about yourself what's your story what's
your background yeah so I was uh raised
the Roman Catholic uh my entire family
is Roman Catholic up until today of
Revelation where Jesus is going to come
which by the way Muslims also believe
that Jesus is the Messiah I personally
never really believed in the religion
primarily because the theology never
really made much sense to me would you
accept with a site called Jew watch
answer that let's think about the deeper
questions in life what's the purpose of
life does God exist what religion is
true their religion is 95 like what Jake
mentioned it's about worshiping God
being devoted to a righteous way of life
loving your neighbors taking care of
your parents that's what 95 of Islam is
about and so I went on this search and
eventually found the path of Islam
primarily because I believe that it's
the only religion today that truly
supports pure monotheism
this seems like it's going to end up
being the round table discussion or what
ended up being a debate
of the year now this is what two career
islamophobes meaning that they attack
Islam and Muslims
for a living
and they're the top players in this 1.3
billion dollar
anti-islam industry one in the arabic
speaking world the one in the English
speaking world now Patrick did a great
job in hosting this we commend him for
that hopefully others will follow suit
and not just talk about Muslims in Islam
but invite qualified Muslims to the
table to the discussion he was Brave and
courageous enough to do that and we're
going to be talking about this
Roundtable discussion with Patrick and
myself and getting his feedback and what
we intend what he tends to do for the
future in this
so again much respect Patrick and
now for this exclusive interview with
Patrick David and myself enjoy God bless
this guy right here this guy's trying to
build a Dallas engineer country I'm not
telling you
talking to yourself you're trying to
build a dawa sensor here Islam is
violent Financial assalamualaikum
brothers and sisters this is exactly why
we need the dean Center because we have
over 300 million Americans who know
nothing about Islam like this guy
yeah
nine is the most violent chapter of the
Quran the D Center will be a source of
light a mega dawa Center an educational
center helping our brothers and sisters
in humanity truly understand Islam and
Muslims and brothers and sisters
remember the great rewards of just
guiding one person in humanity to the
truth is better than everything in this
Dunya so get in on all the rewards and
blessings click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you
[Music]
how you doing brother good how you doing
you're on the dean show now yeah Studios
you don't remind me I was looking at
this picture yes and I um I remember uh
you know growing up I used to have uh I
don't have now at this point now but I
just remember having a Tony Montana The
Godfather all over my apartment yeah you
were that guy and I remember yes that
was my life you and I both but and I see
you taking the direction seeking the
purpose of life you know get turning
more towards God I see myself doing the
same thing and now we we're making a
historic moment I think I really like
the vision that you have trying to get
Christians and work and Muslims to get
past the differences and work together
on some of these commonalities you know
with the sexualization of the children
leave our kids alive
the whole gender ideology a man walked
into the women's bathroom at McDonald's
my daughter goes into those bathrooms
and no man needs to be in there you
understand me oh man you are a man you
are
a man start acting like a man
he recently had a Habib on your program
and we're making history here we just
came out from the
two sides together and tell us what's
your reaction first we almost didn't
almost happen it was a lot that was it
was a lot yeah obviously you you know we
had a uh we had a call with you know
there was a uh misunderstanding from uh
um Muhammad hijab and they made a video
thinking we were going to Ambush them
and we said no we're going to be just
doing a regular discussion together and
then you were able to orchestrate a zoom
between myself yourself and him which
was a phenomenal call and then that led
to Jake coming on and Daniel coming out
which by the way I thought they did a
very good job and Robert Spencer he he
came and he represented his views his
philosophies love him or hate him he did
what he was going to come and do and I
was impressed by Brother Rasheed as well
by the way to me like the two that were
most impressive was brother Rasheed and
Jake because I know of Daniel and I know
of Roberts I know what they were gonna
do
but I was impressed by them the
challenge is with what the goal I have
in mind after spending two and a half
hours with them
progress is going to take a minute it's
not going to happen overnight with one
you know one debate or one discussion or
one podcast or one show we're going to
have to have a lot of these
conversations to realize what's going on
I can tell you for a fact it's going to
be very hard but the enemy is real if we
can figure out a way to see what values
and principles we have in common and
which enemies we have in common then we
can make some progress but if not that
division is constantly going to be there
for a long time to come what do you see
happen because uh you are you even
you're very vocal about this and what
caught my attention was the program you
did with was the pastor or the um the
Charlie Charlie Kirk yep and you were
talking about look if Muslims and
Christians if we can what you in your
words what were you saying yeah what's
the vision because to me I don't
understand why 74 of Muslims vote
Democratic I don't understand it because
that's the party that is more for
leniency with lgbtq with leniency on
what they teach in school with leniency
when it comes out to the family nucleus
the father mother relationship the
father-son relationship the you know the
the ideas they came up with that took in
1940 were only four percent of women who
had kids in America were two single
mothers to today's 40 we went from 1940
in America only four percent of women
were single mothers when they gave birth
to a child today it's 40 those policies
were policies of FDR they were the
policies of Lyndon Johnson they were the
policies of democratic policies I don't
see
the Muslims following those policies and
the way they live so why they vote that
way is very
concerning to me and then on the
Christian side we're saying no no you
know we can't we can't talk to Muslims
we go no no we can't you know it's it's
almost a little bit combative of I
talked to anybody but a different
religion especially Muslim or Christian
I'm trying to see if we can get a way to
uh unify and here's here's the way I
broke it down today we can have the
faith to debate all day long let's do it
okay well Muhammad prophet Muhammad this
or you know Jesus is or Bible Biz or
Quran this or this you can do that all
day long none of us know 100 what's
gonna happen if we die it's all Faith
believe in something you have not yet
seen we could all be wrong we could all
be right one of us could be right and
the rest could be wrong we don't know
that's the risk we're taking I take the
risk as a Christian you take the risk in
a you know as a Muslim right okay then
there is the business side which you
have to respect the fact that how fast
the Muslim religion has grown with their
average in the each women averages 2.9
kids
Christians average 25 2.5 to 2.6 and
non-muslims are 2.2 and the replacement
number is 2.1 you guys you should be at
4.5 by the way 30 years ago 1990 1995 it
was 4.5 4.3 kids per now it's 2.9 so
Christians may be sitting there saying
well it's not fair what's going on that
the Muslim religion is going to be you
know at 3.1 billion you know by 1960 by
2060 and they're going to be 31.1
percent of the population in the world
religious but what are we going to do
about that have more kids they're
competing so you have faith the debate
of Faith you have the business
competitive standpoint of what's growing
then you have common enemy
who is the enemy of Muslims who is the
enemy of Christians and can we find a
common enemy to go after my goal is to
see if we can find this I don't know how
much of a progress we made on today's
show the fact that everybody was willing
to sit down and have the conversation I
think is Step number one that's progress
but I think we got work to do yeah I
think people who who are more in line
with this vision is going to be
important as you want to bring uh
possibly divorce attorneys to uh
marriage reconciliation right what do
you think about when Daniel was he kept
stressing the point of Defending
um Christian traditionalism you know
really going because we strongly believe
that we do have a lot
with traditional Christians that
actually care about the Bible and just
don't don't call it a book of fables we
have values in marriage you know
preserving marriage preserving Chastity
modesty uh you know opposing sexual
immorality preserving gender you know
the concept of gender is so important
that's a shared value with traditional
Christians and traditional Muslims the
importance of the family respecting
parents respecting you know raising
children the right way raising children
to respect these values of morality
communities coming together these are
all shared values they're Traditional
Values do you believe in God belief in
God and and caring about God you know uh
it wasn't really talked about in this
episode but our love for Jesus one of
the most important prophets in Islam is
Jesus Son of Mary you know uh you know
the taste
and Tristan Tate actually makes this
point is there are people in the world
who will punch you in the face if you
insult Jesus Christ you take the
strongest up if you say anything about
Jesus peace be apart we're going to step
outside what are you talking about don't
talk about Jesus you know what I mean or
the Virgin Mary or anything and those
people are the Muslims we love Jesus I
mean things you know there's a whole
chapter in the Quran named after his
Blessed Mother things like this I think
are important there's a lot of a lot of
commonalities and just zooming in on
some of these contentious issues you
know what do you see moving forward like
um with with this part where you know
coming to people who are in that same
who can kind of temper that but just
come for that to really see what you're
seeing you know on both sides where
they're not just going to be on the on
the attack because we could be here all
night bringing up yes and no you know
what I like about today's show brother
Rasheed was the only one that actually
lived in a Muslim Nation outside of
myself he was in Morocco writer he gave
his testimony
Jake was the only one that was
is American that converts to Muslim who
wants to go to Morocco right it was very
interesting
and then Robert Spencer is the you know
coming from a place of the scholar you
know the books he's written and the
enemies he's created and the Jihad watch
which you know then you have Daniel
Harvard you know five Sons he's given
his testimony and I thought he was also
a very good communicator
I thought it was great and I think you
know again I can't wait to do two three
four five of these and seeing where it
takes us next because I realized two
hours is not enough I may only limit it
to two people next time one from each
side and I don't know if I'm gonna do
four again because four you almost feel
obligated to go to everybody and there
can be there yeah yeah battle so I don't
know if I'm gonna go four five total
with myself but
um I learned a lot this was fantastic
for me to hear everybody's testimony I
think there was obviously a good 45
minutes of it that was contentious that
was going back and forth you said this
and you said this and what about this
and what about that so both sides have
to make their own arguments to defend
themselves but I thought it was a lot of
progress yeah I think so I think this
was this was the hardest one I think I
think which is you know the start but I
think if you can push forward and really
you know obviously look you're already
in your mind's already working you know
work through this but I think this was
the hardest one I think you know getting
people on the same vision the same path
I think a lot of good can be account
so so you know I was I was born in Iran
and here in America I get a hold of this
book called power versus Force yeah okay
and I'm 25 years atheist I don't believe
in God because I'm living in Iran I'm
seeing bombing happen people dying I'm
like I'm not having it I go to Germany
at a refugee camp and yeah I do I do
what I do there and I'm around Pakistani
Afghani and I speak Farsi and I'm you
know now I'm a Christian so then I come
here and I'm reading this book called
power versus Force so our book is a
Bible yours is the Quran and I'm reading
power versus Force who was written was
written 20 years ago 30 years ago
and the author talks about levels of
consciousness and life okay from the
lowest level apathy shame guilt anger
I'm probably missing one of them and
then you know desire like Desiring woman
Desiring food Desiring drugs and keeps
going up and up and up and then the
first level of Consciousness that you're
going towards actually making progress
is courage so you're gonna have the
courage to have the conversation
everybody today they had the courage
right for us to have that conversation
then it goes to the next level which if
I don't say it in order it's accepting
acceptance I'm willing to accept that we
have differences okay great then it's
willingness I'm willing to have the
conversation so so far everybody here
today had courage everybody here today
was willing to accept that we have
differences and they were willing to
have the discussion right then it goes
to reason can we reason you seem like
when you and I talk we reason right the
conversations are reason
spiritually you're in a different site
I'm on a different side but we know how
to reason I think the foundation needs
to also be built that we set aside faith
and we're able to reason then comes love
joy then it's Enlightenment at the
highest level and he only explains that
only a couple people haven't made it to
Enlightenment Enlightenment is a
different level reason is a very
valuable
quality we need nowadays if we don't
have reason we don't sit together if we
don't have reason we don't want to talk
to each other if we don't have reason
we're not going to do these kinds of
things so as long as we have courage
we're willing we're willing to accept
our differences and are able to reason
what I wanted to destroy each other I
think will make progress if we don't
have those things there's going to be no
progress I think we made progress today
I think we really did make progress I
was watching um one of your interviews
and it was very interesting what had you
because the main theme of the dean show
is getting people to think beyond the
materialism beyond the material world
you know purpose purpose of life and it
was interesting at one point you were
you're talking about the things what was
your God at one point right and how you
how did you get to the point where you
started reflecting and started to think
and I think you said you said what was
you said uh
women women was my guy oh all day yeah
that was my yeah I mean I I that can
that should just can be a point for
anything you know and that's of course
you know yeah and and that's something
there there's actually um that's
something for for myself I can relate
yeah so I related to that you know those
and and but taking it so you started to
you're starting to think more outside of
just that and getting to you know yeah
at the stage of your life where you're
at now and by the way if you've never
met Eddie he's six three just so you
know yeah I thought he was like five
eight five ten he's six three but uh
yeah so you know I'm having this
conversation with this YouTuber called
cramp Stefan super successful business
guy young guy 3233 or multi-millionaire
done very well from so it's got like
four or five million subscribers and he
says to me you know one of the co-hosts
asked a question about God you know it
seems like God plays a very big role in
your life I said you know everybody has
a God right some people's God's video
games some it's porn some it's worse
drugs some it's alcohol some it's
partying some what's this when I was an
atheist
I may have claimed I didn't have a God
but I did have a God it was party and it
was nightlife it was women that was my
party that's what I was you considered
yourself an atheist at one point
absolutely I was an atheist for 25 years
I didn't believe I got kicked out of
Bible study school for 25 years I got
kicked out in Iran I got kicked out of
schools for a Bible study for just
saying I don't believe in God you guys
think you need this you need this I
don't need this if God existed why did
we have War why did these people die so
I wasn't a part of it and then one day
my dad is at the hospital at UCLA
Medical Center after he had a big heart
attack and I'm sitting there and you
know the hospital is not really taking
care of him they're not attending to him
I didn't get half I wasn't happy about
it I got upset with the people that were
working or they kicked me out of the
hospital so I'm downstairs in my Ford
Focus and I'm just sitting there crying
this is my dad I mean this is my hero so
six years old he's been my guy he's been
my hero
and then I gradually whether it was a
man who gave me a Bible in the military
when I was 1997 or later on when I
started doing Bible study uh uh Friday
Nights from six o'clock till two o'clock
in the morning or when I was going to
anybody and everybody I could find to
debate Scientology or Catholicism or you
know Jehovah Witness or seven-day
Adventist or Mormonism I was just
debating everybody any chance I get I
wanted to debate anybody with the topic
of religion at one point I thought I was
maybe going to be a pastor and then
I see my dad could potentially die
change my habits changed my life stopped
doing anything with women and the rest
is history for me from there my life
changed completely changed and the fact
that my dad is 81 years old right now
still alive let me tell you biggest
blessing so God's grace to a regular guy
like me has been seen and felt so many
times he's given me so he has so much
grace over this regular guy right that
now I don't sit there claiming I live a
perfect life I'm a sinner I have
temptations I do a lot of different
things all of us do but I feel God is
right now looking for people to rise up
and lead and that's the relationship I
have with them I want to be one of those
that he can count on a couple more
things how was your experience now going
you went down to actually meet with
Andrew Tate and what do you what what do
you see happening with this and what was
Andrew's loud man Andrews loud Andrew's
a great that uh he can be an
intellectual guy he can be a driver he
can be a troll he can be a you know
sarcastic he can be funny he's a
comedian he's a non-duplicatable
communicator and Andrew is one of one
there is no 25 Andrews there's only one
Andrew tape in the world and you know uh
the way they've targeted him they've
done what have done but my experiences
with him that we've spent time together
has been nothing but a breath of fresh
air I've not partied with them I've not
gone out with him I didn't know the 22
year old Andrew or the 28 Orlando the
Andrew that I've seen him the multiple
times him and his brother uh Tristan I
can tell you
you know in the area of women Tristan's
game is a very unique game he is a
little bit too handsome Tristan's style
is a he's the guy that he's just there
to back up his brother and defend him
and no one can do anything to Andrew
is a revolutionary type of a character
he's going to be targeted he's going to
be he's going to have enemies for the
rest of his life it's never going to
slow down for Andrew the only time
they're going to stop targeting Camp is
after his last video if he stops making
videos or says anything or tweets
they'll stop targeting him for as long
as Andrew is going to be opening his
mouth and tweeting and talking he's
going to be targeting they're not going
to slow down with Andrew but I think
he's a True Believer that he wants to
fight and I think his voice is necessary
and he calls out a lot of these things
that you also have an objection to me as
Muslims and Christians this whole
spectrum of genders you believe how many
genders are there too like when you
asked yeah it could be brilliant in
Russia how many jails I live in the
mountains my brother there's only two
genders when I went to the bathroom he
was given the story right so we can
agree on that and there's a lot more and
with that said I just want to commend
you because
um you with this Vision I strongly
believe in it and us working together in
a commonality a common good we don't
have to compromise you know you people
have their strict beliefs they want to
stick to it it but we share that's the
model of Denisha because we care we
share and it's up to you you want to
take except if not rejected but at the
same time we don't have to be at each
other's throats we like I like that
analogy you gave people are cursing you
understand you're like okay but the next
come after your children realize that
what they're trying to do to our kids
none of us agree with
you know none of us agree with you know
the whole saying goes that somebody can
curse you out and you're like yeah
whatever Robert you're such a f in this
okay cool hey you know you're such a f
in this all right cool hey let me tell
you you know you're a loser cool all
right hey I'm gonna turn your kids into
teaching them about lgbtq at five years
old I'm sorry
what did you say there's a catalyst for
that and there's been many examples of
Muslims of Christians coming together
and we can come together on other things
what do you think I totally agree I'm
with you there I'm with you there let us
be an example to that amen God thank you
this wouldn't happen today without what
he what you pulled off and you know I
want to get I said that on the podcast I
want to make sure your audience knows
very important thank you very much thank
you appreciate it I cannot leave without
giving you a gift if you are not yet
Muslim and you tune in to see what these
Muslims are talking about and you like a
free copy of the Quran go and visit
thedineshow.com we'll take care of the
postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you